Two cars collide fighting
for the first lap position.
Here comes a leader.
He dives into the turn.
I'm Dale Earnhardt Jr.
And I'm on a journey.
A journey to find and explore
old abandoned race tracks.
A journey that retraces
the footsteps of my heroes.
And immortalizes
their greatness...
Green flag is waving.
...at the very places in
which they excel.
Down the beach full throttle,
accelerating, sliding,
shifting in split seconds.
A journey that seeks closure
for anyone forced to cope
with the grief of losing
their beloved speedway.
I've learned everything about
life right here on this asphalt.
A journey that when it
started, I had no idea
one of those people
would be me.
That's crazy.